Despite her future successes, Nancy Wake had
humble beginnings.
She was born in Wellington, New Zealand in
1912, but her family moved to Sydney, Australia
when she was almost two and she grew up there.
A Maori midwife delivered her and, at the
time of her birth, allegedly pointed at a
fold of skin on her head and said, “’This
is what we call a kahu, and it means your
baby will always be lucky.
Wherever she goes, whatever she does, the
gods will look after her.”
Her childhood didn’t appear to be very lucky.
When she was four, just a few short years
after the move to Sydney, her father left
on a trip to the United States and never returned.
This left her frazzled mother to look after
six children, of whom Wake was the youngest.
She was constantly butting heads with her
mother and, at the age of sixteen, she left
home to work as a nurse.
She might have continued working independently
in Sydney had it not been for the unexpected
inheritance of £200 (about £11,500 today)
from her aunt which allowed her to seek out
adventure.
Arriving in London in 1932, she started a
course in journalism.
Her new career took her to Paris, where she
lived for a year reporting on the situation
in Europe as well as the rise of Nazism.
However, she had time for fun, too, and took
full advantage of Parisian nightlife.
Soon, the girl from humble beginnings had
charmed Henri Fiocca, a French millionaire.
They married shortly after the start of World
War II and she moved into his mansion in Marseilles.
Wake was a working woman, however, and despised
the Nazis.
She could not abide sitting back while they
marched into France.
As such, she joined up with the local Resistance
movement, acting as a courier.
She became an invaluable part of the Resistance
movement, carrying important messages from
one resistance group to another.
It took the Nazis a while to figure out they
were being duped by a beautiful, outwardly
flirtatious woman, but when they did, they
hunted her fiercely, eventually even putting
a 5 million franc bounty on her head.
However, the Gestapo wasn’t able to catch
Wake.
Whenever they seemingly had her cornered,
she managed to slip away unnoticed.
Because of this, they called her “the White
Mouse.”
She was very nearly captured once, in an incident
that saw bullets whistling past her ears,
but she managed to make it over the Pyrenees
by herself, once again evading capture.
Talking about her close calls, she said, “I
never had time to worry.
And I have to admit, though some people won’t
believe me, I was never afraid.”
From Spain she made her way to Britain, where
she trained for sixteen weeks with the Special
Operations Executive.
At the end of this intense training, she was
something of an expert in explosives, hand-to-hand
combat, and weaponry.
She was ready for her first mission: to assess
resistance groups in France and let London
know what each group needed in terms of munitions.
We all know that war was largely a “man’s”
game back then, though, and despite parachuting
into the forests of l’Auvergne to carry
out her duties, she was met with many resistance
fighters who couldn’t believe that Britain
had sent in a woman for this job.
They refused to treat her with respect—that
is, until she challenged the leaders to drinking
contests which she nearly always won (in true
Australian form.
Later, she mentioned that she liked to consume
at least six gin and tonics a day).
In doing so, she was able to take some 7000
resistance partisans under her wing.
When D-Day arrived, Wake commanded her “troops,”
organizing them to fight against the German
soldiers rushing to reinforce their fellows
at Normandy.
She and the resistance fighters blew up bridges
and wrecked trains, narrowly escaping capture.
As if all of that wasn’t enough, Wake also
killed a German sentry with her bare hands
to prevent him from alerting the rest of the
men that an attack was in full swing.
Later, they liberated Vichy which had been
in the hands of collaborationists.
It soon became clear that the Allies were
going to win the war.
Allowed into a recently liberated Paris, Wake
and her friends found themselves at the British
Officers Club acting a bit rowdy.
The waiter serving them boldly proclaimed
that he would rather be serving German soldiers
than put up with them for another moment.
An angry Wake told him exactly how she felt
by “knocking him senseless with a right-hook.”
A fellow waiter came running with a shot of
brandy to revive the poor man.
Nancy grabbed the shot instead, drained it,
and said “Merci” before walking out the
door.
After the war, Wake was decorated with medals
from the United States, Britain, and France.
It was sixty years before she would be granted
medals from her native Australia and New Zealand
because she hadn’t served with the Australian
forces during the war.
In subsequent years, she was offered Australian
medals but systematically refused them.
At one point, she said,
‘The last time there was a suggestion of
giving me [an Australian medal], I told the
government they could stick their medals where
the monkey stuck his nuts.
The thing is if they gave me a medal now,
it wouldn’t be given with love so I don’t
want anything from them.
They can bugger off!
However, Australia did eventually make her
a Companion of the Order of Australia in 2004;
in 2006, she was granted an RSA Badge in Gold
from New Zealand.
It wasn’t until the war ended that she learned
her husband, Henri, had been captured by the
Gestapo in 1943.
He was grilled about her whereabouts but refused
to say anything that might lead them to her.
He also refused to say anything about her
activities.
For his attempt to save her, he was executed.
Wake always blamed herself for his death,
adding that “Henri was the love of my life.”
In her later years, she returned to Sydney
with her second husband, RAF pilot and former
prisoner of war John Forward.
She tried several times to run for politics
with the Liberal Party of Australia, but was
never elected.
Nevertheless, she and her husband were quite
happy, living together in Sydney until he
died in 1997.
In 2001, at the age of 89, she packed up and
moved back to London.
Wake suffered a heart attack in 2003, but
she kept on fighting until 2011 when, at the
age of 98, she passed away following a chest
infection.
She lived to see her story memorialized in
books, TV, and movies.
The character of Charlotte Gray in the book
by the same name by Sebastian Faulks, which
was later turned into a movie with the title
character played by Cate Blanchette, is based
on the exploits of Nancy Wake and other female
operatives during World War II.
After her death, Wake was cremated and her
ashes were scattered in France near the mountains
where she fought with
the Resistance.